[Music]
purchase purchase purchase even more
birches yes
thousands of birches everywhere what is
it about ooh meow and its passion for
birch trees I'm sorry you know community
art until some crew in the affected
country out of your town or Carrie nice
dawn saw it something about families an
ethnographer trip and the residents of
email they use the birch for just about
everything they use them for art they
are painted on art they become furniture
decorate houses they color fabrics make
medicine of birch glue and soaps they
make tea and mixed drinks wait what is
that right drink birch Artman dude from
Kahoot bro a cop that will cheer up boy
a minute available at mcgill way up from
here a snap station pum but about even
bullet digger it looks on sattibabu cut
off free estimate three Kappa Eric so
Adams movie are played on oxy yeah
Tokuda a toy a Salib even in the winter
when the birches are bare and ugly they
brighten up the town but then you have
to go indoors to peek at them
[Music]
but why is everyone in umeå so crazy for
birches given that it's winter most of
the year
wouldn't Pines have been a more natural
choice - get our main hallo master
eminence militant hernia and beauty
bestowed to FEM 2% about them okay time
for trip back into history let's rewind
to oomiya in 1888 back then the whole
town was more or less built of wood on
june 25th a fire broke out in the city's
brewery gale force winds caused the fire
to spread and grow to a disastrous size
the whole town burned down Yanam of
Kaliyuga up stallions very well it
picked up the Indra and New Zealand are
sort of Aldermen 20 Rob your garrison in
the holy Mickey bottom for a CW Yahoo
son that sounds pretty brilliant does it
actually work
yeah come chatter Lamia steered the hood
they removed store environment and
filters wrong impurity man they we begin
to vote technique of dark red for their
dogs man that day o'clock DeAndre
historia not everyone is impressed by
these trees lots of residents here
suffer from pollen allergies some so
strong that they can't bear to go
outside for parts of the year so how the
locals coexist with their city symbol is
their solution to this problem yeoman
absolute jargon till example the swamp
so Mexico p.m. then in holy Mickey mr
öktem on town cook at the airport on or
visa say Stella Mary be free from sin
Allegheny anomaly cadet do you dare
trust the tea seems like it's worth a
visit to find out yourself
you
[Music]